Україна має бути в НАТО якомога швидше і без процедури Плану дій щодо членства.
Про це останнім часом багато говорили західні експерти, дипломати
та військові перед самітом Альянсу, який має відбутися 11-12 липня у Вільнюсі.
Та чи запросять там Україну в НАТО? Остаточного рішення досі немає.
Країни-члени Альянсу намагаються подолати розбіжності.
Склалася парадоксальна ситуація.
Є українська армія, яка найбільш загартована у боях і найбільш готова
відповідати на загрози - такі, як Росія.
Не запросити країну, яка найбільше готова відбивати загрози, - це парадокс.
З іншого боку, в основі НАТО є механізм політичного консенсусу,
подолати який дуже важко. НАТО продовжуватиме підтримувати Україну, надавати зброю.
Війна Росії проти України стала сигналом. Я особисто вважаю, що він,
вочевидь, був недостатньо сильним, аби всі остаточно прокинулися в Європі.
Деякі країни подвоїли інвестиції в оборону, деякі лише трохи.
Усвідомлення реальної небезпеки, особливо у західних столицях Європи,
ще поки немає. Не знаю, що має статися, щоб усі почали приводити НАТО у стан,
в якому він був. Україна надала сенс НАТО.
На думку експертів, є декілька варіантів розвитку подій із запрошенням України в НАТО.
Зокрема, це прискорений шлях після припинення війни без жодних умов
або з умовою успішної боротьби з корупцією,
проведенням судової реформи та інших реформ в країні.
Може бути і традиційний ПДЧ - план дій щодо членства з усім спектром
консультацій і допомоги на шляху до вступу в НАТО.
Ще один варіант - меморандум, що Україна неодмінно стане членом Альянсу
із зазначенням конкретної дати, до якої це має статися.
Водночас Чарльз Купчан, який працював спецпомічником
президента США Барака Обами, коли почалася війна на Донбасі,
радить Києву на даному етапі менше перейматися питанням членства в НАТО
та чи буде найближчим часом пропозиція про вступ,
натомість більше сконцентруватися на плані конкретної
військової допомоги Україні.
Більша частина конкретного прогресу, досягнутого на саміті,
стосуватиметься отримання Україною необхідної військової допомоги
та обговорення з окремими державами-членами НАТО політичних відносин
і гарантій безпеки. Усередині НАТО немає консенсусу
щодо основного - питання членства.
І доки не буде цього консенсусу та згоди країн-членів НАТО,
можливо, 32-ох, після того як Швеція приєднається до Альянсу,
вони не зможуть взяти на себе конкретні зобов’язання
з надання запрошення Україні.
І як наслідок, я думаю, ми побачимо надихаючі промови,
заохочувальні слова, але нічого такого, що могло би стати
залізобетонною гарантією щодо термінів
чи особливостей членства України в НАТО.
У США та країнах Західної Європи, зокрема Німеччині,
ретельно зважують ризики та загрози ескалації з боку Росії,
яка називала розширення НАТО на схід одним із приводів війни з Україною.
Натомість країни Східної та Центральної Європи виступають
за конкретний механізм залучення України в НАТО і нагадують,
що політика стримування Росії провалилася і не може бути
довгострокового миру в регіоні без вступу України в НАТО.
Тривають дискусії і щодо гарантій безпеки для України
з боку окремих потужних країн. Наприклад, ізраїльська модель,
коли США зобов'язалися підтримувати Ізраїль зброєю та в інший спосіб.
Чи може це стати альтернативою повноцінному
членству України в НАТО?
Ми не розглядаємо альтернатив - ані на рівні президента, ані на інших.
Ізраїльська модель звучить непогано, але цього замало.
Я знаю, як Ізраїль досягнув рівня безпеки, і що вони для цього зробили.
Не варто забувати про ізраїльську ядерну силу, хай і неофіційну.
Це відрізняється від ситуації в Україні, яка добровільно відмовилася
від ядерної зброї та її носіїв, передавши це Росії.
Це була велика помилка, але не України, а США, які думали, що Росія
піде демократичним шляхом.
Якщо ми говоримо про Ізраїль, то це фінансова та військова підтримка.
Україна отримує велику підтримку не лише від США,
а й від європейських країн та країн, не членів НАТО.
Ізраїль в особливій ситуації, ця країна менша, ніж Україна.
Я не думаю, що Україна житиме під загрозою нападів щодня.
Ми продемонструємо, що будь-який напад у майбутньому спричинить
негайну відповідь.
Відверто кажучи, я не хочу ізраїльську модель. Але я хотів би для України
угоди з однією з країн, які мають ядерну зброю - зі США, Британією чи Францією.
Ці країни надали Україні запевнення у безпеці - Будапештський меморандум.
Я вважаю, що ізраїльська модель - для Ізраїлю.
Україна матиме свою модель, і я вважаю, що ця модель
означатиме: Україна в НАТО.
Формальну заявку на вступ Україна подала ще у вересні 2022 року.
Київ неодноразово заявляв, що чекає від саміту у Вільнюсі конкретних кроків.
Одним з них стане підвищення статусу створеної ще у 1997 році
комісії Україна-НАТО до рівня ради.
Перше засідання на рівні голів держав та урядів має відбутися 12 липня.
Оглядачі це називають "втішним призом", оскільки зробити
формальне запрошення НАТО навряд чи зможе.
Мені важко уявити, що НАТО збирається запропонувати Україні членство,
доки не буде стабільної, безпечної ситуації. Дехто каже:
а чому НАТО не може просто надати гарантії тим частинам України,
які під її контролем, так само, як це поширювалося на Західну Німеччину,
але не на Східну?
Головна відмінність полягає в тому, що зараз триває війна,
і якщо НАТО поширить свою 5-ту статтю на ті частини країни,
які контролюються Києвом, Альянс зіткнеться з перспективою
вступити у війну з Росією.
Якби бомба впала на Київ, Одесу, Львів чи будь-де, і НАТО не зміг би
відреагувати на прямий напад на Київ, це фактично розвалило б Альянс.
Тому НАТО не хоче опинитися в такому становищі.
Тим не менше, експерти і дипломати продовжують тиснути на західні столиці
з вимогою підтримати запрошення України в НАТО вже нині,
щоб запустити незворотний процес, який врешті-решт призведе
до вступу України в Альянс і покладе край амбіціям Росії
відновити імперію. Оглядачі стверджують, що це історичний крок
і кращого шансу, ніж на саміті у Вільнюсі, для цього не буде.
Водночас більшість експертів схиляються до того, що результатом саміту в Вільнюсі
стане проміжне рішення, а формальне запрошення України до Альянсу
може відбутися вже на наступному -
ювілейному 75-му саміті НАТО у Вашингтоні.